well let's let's let's do this let me
see if I can pull up this uh let's talk
about what what I'll tell you what
really scares me man what not being able
to say I'm proud to be an American
anymore
it's not about that it feels like it I
mean they're right now yeah you did you
what did you post you post something
about Trump and some called you a Nazi I
I straight-up said I'm proud to be an
American
tweet yeah that's it send tweet Nazi
it's like are you kidding me because I'm
proud of where I live because I'm proud
of my country because because we we went
from having slavery to getting rid of it
to hold on
slavery was a global institution it
still is that's a great point Tim and
and not only did we beat it we were in
the forefront of showing how to change
things and I mean we weren't the first
okay and we're not gonna be the last no
no I think we were we're actually way
behind most countries really so the UK
abolished at first at some point we
abolished it through a war you know that
we won actually than the Union won we're
the Union we're the good guys yep the
bad guys lost yes and in other parts of
the world it still exists yeah that's
true
but this is but here's the point I'm
bringing up yes you can't even say
you're proud to be American right now
Los Angeles Mayor Eric Garcetti bands
4th of July fireworks displays prohibits
gatherings with people you don't live
with puts hard pause on movie theater
reopening now there was a question about
sort of is he banning fireworks because
of the potential for fires what I
thought but it sounds like what they're
saying is don't go out and gather with
people because of kovat this period will
be our second big test it is now time
for a pause
we simply cannot risk people's lives
it's ridiculous he then announced along
with beach closures 4th of July
fireworks displays would be prohibited
in the hope of keeping Angelenos from
gathering in groups boom they don't care
what did Muriel Bowser say in DC hmm
stay home on the 4th of July yep what
did she say a couple weeks or a week or
so before March she didn't say anything
she was literally marching with the
protesters yep exactly so I'll tell you
what scares me
it's not that people aren't allowed to
be proud to be American anymore that
freaks me out for sure nothing really
scares me when you get a regular
American who doesn't read the news
doesn't care to read the news and all
they're thinking is
and this fourth is gonna be awesome man
I haven't seen Jimmy how long has it
been Jimmy I haven't seen you in it's in
three years man mm-hmm and now you know
Jimmy is coming down and Rick and Dale
and Harry and we're gonna get together
crack some beers cook up some brats by
the lake go fishing the kids are gonna
be there we ran out the dogs in a beat
it's gonna be awesome
then you got younger people who are like
you know all cool we're gonna go out
we're gonna fireworks you got older
people are like yeah I remember back
when we used to have the firework
celebration down by the now by the river
and out all gone you know it's not just
about being American it's about people
wanting to be with the ones they love
and a special time of year where they
get to it's it's summer you know if they
get to have burgers with the people they
care about they get to laugh love live
and now the mayor and across this
country are saying you cannot have a
good time with those you care about but
we will absolutely march in your faces
yeah as your businesses rot to the
ground and are burned by rioters we will
smile we'll shoot it yeah yep they had
the protesters are shooting at people
the people are just going about their
day it's like oh are you driving this
way boom we're shooting layout and then
what's the response in the government
how dare that the person's rival
protesters my favorite thing was the BBC
they said 27 officers injured in a
peaceful protest right Wow
yeah that's insane this is what this is
so this freaks me out the media what
will the reaction be of regular
Americans who are sick and tired of
being stepped on with with jackboots you
know these these governors who are
enacting unconstitutional orders the
police who fight the Constitution with a
smile on their face not although mostly
in bigger cities smaller town cops seem
to be doing all right
yeah but these but the bigger cities
they don't care they're just like
governor said you know I allowed to have
a Constitution so you're under arrest
don't care for you don't care and I'm
and I'm defensive of the police right
now and as it pertains to defund the
police but look man I think they're one
of the reasons they're losing a lot of
support is because when the governor
said hey you know the Constitution is
over the cops are just like you got it
happy to accept that paycheck so so so
yes right now check us
we've got la saying we can't at risk
people's lives we get stories like this
three and four say attending fourth of
July celebrations is risky says pol my
goodness this makes me question what
we're hearing in the media here's my
question do American have Americans
given up have they lost their sense of
nation do they no longer care about what
America is what stands for there's
definitely them out there there's
definitely Americans that have no idea
what America actually is yeah they're
spoiled entitled and they're clueless
ignorant yeah well so this is the big
question is is the majority of this
country still proud to be an American
even even only a little bit I think that
is a true statement that's this is
something I've been this is this is the
reason I've been saying the things I've
been saying over the past few months
because I believe that I believe the
majority are proud to be Americans
there's plenty of people who have just
recently come to America like over the
past 20 years that are like you have no
idea what I went through to even be here
to have the yeah the little job that I
have that I get minimum wage that job is
amazing and I love my rights that I have
here that I had none of when I where I
came from and it's like yes it all it
shows to me is these people are ignorant
they have no idea what they really have
so why why are all these governors and
mayors banning the 4th of July this
right here money this is why yeah money
because they're getting paid by
something somewhere somebody's agenda to
to undermine America America is a big
thorn in the New World Order the whole
like trying to Rican you know I don't
know you know do redo the whole globe
essentially under you know a regime you
know China's probably wants us to kill
ourselves
I think much it's kind of happening yeah
yeah sure that was a leap but but it but
you asked me to deepen your voice what
is the reason they're doing it it's like
why would they why would they want to
undermine America probably because
they're getting paid by somebody who
doesn't want
America do exist anymore I think it's
simpler than that I think if they
weren't pathetic spineless little you
know weasels they'd ban black lives
matter protests - the only reason
they're not doing is because these
people went around smashing windows and
burning buildings to the ground okay and
so it's like I said what we're seeing is
morality government its morality
policing when they say it's easier just
to give the protesters what they want
and strip the rights of other people
then than to deal with the mob and
that's what it is so they're sitting
there they're looking at a mob throwing
Molotov cocktails you know and people
like us who are just in our home
complaining and they're like well these
guys obey the law so I don't got to
worry about them
these guys are burning everything down
how can we play Kate them oh just get
what they want you got it and so they do
and that's what's scaring me because
you're gonna see the breaking point for
regular Americans when they're like no
no I can't I can't do this that's what
I'm that's what I've been saying there's
gonna be a point where a lot of
Americans are like you know what fine
I'm gonna go open my gun locker and now
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go out and
actually exercise my rights let them try
to come on my property
flex of July what everyone's talking
about this Seattle couple memes are
flying off the tailless oh is it yes
excuse me st. Louis they're flying off
the shelves all the memes they're
amazing memes by the way Saving Private
amazing names seriously the meme
factories are running they never quit
Cova didn't stop them but I mean they
were they were coming on to private
property they walked out to protect
themselves if they didn't have those
guns and they were standing there like
get out of here they would have been
attacked they were on private property
it's like they had every right to stand
there and I'm like you're gonna get on
Facebook and I'm like oh my gosh like
what are what is this crap I'm seeing
like everyone's just ridiculing it's
it's like a cesspool of anti Trump anti
anything that goes against the narrative
that I mean and now that we know about
modulated project Veritas it's like
Facebook is clearly biased deleting
everything that they can get their hands
on that is pro Trump or not even pro
Trump anti what they're pushing you know
I think it's it's scary oh it's you know
I jokingly say the Democrats want Trump
to win mm-hmm but it really does feel
like it it feels like you don't even
care about Trump
they want America to just burn that's
what they use like well but the joke I'm
making is how could you fail like a
broken clock is Right twice a day
yep but Democrats have been wrong
literally everything they've done the
only conclusion I can come to is that
it's on purpose
yeah um pump like wow are you really
just that bad at what you do that's
impossible
you'd eventually get something right
would think but they don't they're like
what is the riots accomplished and we
stand they supported them and then
banned the 4th of July are you crazy
yeah yeah and then the Democrats tweet
that was deleted about Mount Rushmore
like calling out did you bring this do
we have this up come on come I don't I
don't know I don't think I do actually
oh man but earlier we did but here's
here's what I gotta say I need to I need
to issue a correction to mr. Dan
Crenshaw oh yeah yes a correction si si
Dan tweeted out the image of for those
unfamiliar Republican congressman from
Texas he tweeted an image of the tweet
and said they were calling Mount
Rushmore racist hmm that is not true oh
they were calling the rally he was
having racist at Mount Rushmore and on
July 4 the rally was the 4th of July
celebration right the point is they were
saying celebrating the 4th of July is a
glorifies white supremacy and he was
doing it at Mount Rushmore so they
weren't necessarily I get it better
they're disparaging Mount Rushmore no
it's substantially worse yeah if you're
aligned if it's one thing that they
sadly we respect your right to celebrate
independence but doing it here is you
know offensive to some communities I'd
still cringe at that instead they were
straight up like this rally Trump is
having which is a 4th of July
celebration glorifies white supremacy
well they think it they believe it
that's what they think they really do
the masks lit yes and there it is
beneath the thin veneer of a smiling
pro-america social justice activist is a
lunatic who wants to burn this country
to the ground you know not every single
Democrat obviously of course but there
are enough of them within this group and
you get that there's no leadership so
Nancy Pelosi what does she do she gets
unbent me and and and swears fealty to
the fringe ideology yo and then she
can't even stand up and so I was wearing
a Ken take off
which is which it which is the us it
which was worn by slave traders yep
yeah very powerful slave trading empire
these people are lunatics yeah it's like
they're brazenly showing it off to like
they don't care the Democratic Party was
the racist party who's that who's that
former Klansmen who was kissing Hillary
Clinton that famous photo Oh Robert Byrd
is that his name yeah he's always been a
Democrat right I believe that's the
funniest thing double check that he's a
Klan member yeah and then he and then
apparently he has like a moment of like
revelation and he's still a Democrat
mm-hm and so people show this photo of
the guy like with Hillary in there
laughing and smiling together and it's
like what makes you think this guy
changed when he's still with the same
part it's do the same thing and I want
to make sure I make it clear the
complaints the activists have about
police about politicians are all in
democratically controlled areas they're
not complaining about Republicans
absolutely right has he always been a
Democrat I believe so not only that like
the Republicans are trying to pass
police reform laws they blocked it and
who blocked it the Democrat and they
called and they called timpz they
insulted Tim Scott yeah oh man I was
they called him a token yeah they called
it a token a token you know or whatever
and he got really offended like that
it's insane and he ate man
dude that I can't stand these people man
Rand Paul he put a bill forward to stop
no-knock rates and it's like good that's
what we need to stop that yeah you know
it's like what is going on like how is
this how are you not why are you
blocking these that was I was in
Portland there trying to keep it around
there I was in Portland and there was
like a rat a big rally of mostly like
right-wing groups you had Patriot
Prairie and proud boys is a very typical
thing yeah and one of the proud boys was
a black man okay so you know what anti
if I started doing what they started
yelling as many racial slurs as they had
would Wow
and I was standing there and this dude
went off good and he's like he's wearing
a vest and he's like I think he was a
veteran and he's like very much in shape
the police separated the groups and so
all the proud boys and patron on one
side all Antep on the other side and the
Antipa people start yelling hardcore
racial slurs I was like I could
believe what I was hearing and I could
believe it and so this dude one of the
proud boys he gets super angry and he
goes to cross the street where the
police have separated everybody and the
other guys grabbed him and I'm looking
at these this funny these proud boys and
they're holding him back and they're
looking him in the eyes and saying you
were my brother man like we are here
with you you are one of us don't listen
to what these people are saying they're
trying to make you angry so you go over
there and fight them but yeah and they
were saying things like we're here with
you we're all equal you're with you're
one of us ignore what they're saying and
I'm sitting here like none of these
people on the right we're saying racial
slurs not a single not a single one all
right and I've always had to put people
man it was it was crazy what they were
saying because they use emotions that's
how that's they're racists
absolutely absolutely emotional you can
racist you can look this up they were
there was an ice protest and I believe
it was Portland and there was a black
cop and they are yelling crazy racial
slurs they are saying like you name the
racial slur they are saying it it's it's
him you did you find it yeah it's it
from 2018 I'm not gonna repeat what they
were saying so they did say a couple of
the hard slurs but they also use terms
associated with like I'm not gonna say
what they are referencing black people
who are servants essentially okay like
clear traitors right no no no like I'm
not gonna say it but just just trust me
there's there's like 12 probably 20
different terms and they're all just
talking and saying things and they're
doing a certain kind of accent you know
it's like man I have seen some stuff
from these people semester now look man
I've encountered my share of backwater
white yokel racists like I told the
story last week about being in in I
think I was in Dallas and I'd an uber
driver who was overtly racist right I
started getting angry because he was
saying he was very very stupid and then
he shut up I've also I've also
experienced like when I briefly lived in
Virginia some serious racism from other
generations but the funny thing about
these people is they know to keep their
mouths shut you know I mean like they
understand what's socially acceptable
and they may be bigots but they just
they'll stop okay so so I can I can tell
them straight up hey you know don't talk
like that I'm not interested in hearing
that you know you can you can speak like
that you want to speak somebody else fun
but don't bring a rahmet
but you look at an taifa they claim to
be fighting racism and come out in the
streets and scream racial slurs at
people that's look at the joke look at
square that look at the video of the
that we talked about this this this you
know 18 year old girl getting arrested
by you know and she's crying
hyperventilating and they're like she
needs ruderalis ooze which is ridiculous
but they call it they starts yelling
racial slurs in the black cop walks up
this mess you can you see it happens
look man it's like aren't they out for
black lives matter that was you see
right all right yeah you see that video
try it out where the guy in the in the
in the golf cart you know raises his
fist and yells something pretty dumb I'm
not gonna repeat it and horrible and it
seemed like he was trying to be ironic
right but I'm not but but it was a
moronic yeah he was like yeah yeah
whatever and it was stupid it was stupid
and the media went nuts the meat was
like watching road
yummy videos I could find right now of
leftist screaming racial slurs and they
never bring it up in the news or how
about joe biden his racial slurs that
he's said over the years like i've seen
some stuff about what he's saying it's
like that dudes racist yeah clearly
clearly to be fair line not only is he
racist
his family had slaves why aren't they
freaking out and tearing down his to be
fair the latest yeah a lot of a lot of
the actual progressives call him out for
these things okay it's the establishment
that won't do it yeah so you you you
know you'll find them actually saying
things like why would I support Biden
Biden's racist right mm-hmm
which brings me to an interesting
thought I had so I was talking to you
know I've been I've been bound to these
ideas around a couple people you know I
know in the political world and I was
like what do you think would happen like
you think the possibly the possibility
is that Trump only gets forty percent of
the popular vote but still wins because
progressive Democrats don't vote for
Biden and vote for a third party yeah so
let's say you know Trump barely gets
enough electoral votes to win nearly and
his in the popular vote forty percent so
everyone's outraged but Joe Biden only
gets thirty six right and then some
third party gets you know do some good
get fourteen or whatever gets there are
yeah gets the remaining maybe maybe not
maybe
Bernie Sanders write-ins and I'm
thinking this because on the ballot
right I think he is is no I don't know
about that I thought it was but on the
primary ballots yeah maybe
okay the reason I was thinking about
this is that we're not when when Trump
released issued his press release
showing Joe Biden's enthusiasm mm-hmm in
Alaska
he got 55 percent of the Democratic
primary vote and he's the only one
running what 55 because other people
were still on and so people were like I
don't care if they quit I'm gonna vote
for him anyway right so all you need is
10% of the Democratic base to be alike
we want Bernie and we're voting for
Bernie no matter what yeah and then
Biden doesn't you know Trump doesn't get
the majority think about the insanity
that would ensue if Trump got a
magistrate's 35 percent of the of the
popular vote okay but Biden and Bernie
split it evenly and come under at like
30 percent each mm-hmm and then you know
then you got third party spilled in in
everywhere else people would lose their
minds it would be out be it would be
absolutely nuts I wonder what the
possibility that maybe it's true that
Trump's base right now is only 35% I
don't even believe what's the plurality
of voters yeah you know so like it's not
so much about who gets the most who gets
who gets the majority it's about who
gets the most so if you have too many
candidates who are more in the race
Trump could win with it with a small
minority unless of course he hasn't come
in he doesn't get 270 electoral votes
then everything just becomes chaos
that's another potential for civil war
nobody gets to 70 and then it's just a
you know everybody's freaking out and
screaming at each other yeah all right
yeah you know man I'll tell you what
it's gonna be the most exciting November
of my life ah gonna be fun we got to
order pizza say for me I'm gonna be
sitting here with you we're gonna be
we're gonna be hopefully in the in
somewhere new in a new new area in a new
area for the new projects and Tim's
proximity I hope yeah well we'll be
we'll be in a similar space and we'll
see what happened to November thanks for
checking out this clip from the Tim cast
IRL podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune into this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you